[Musique]
faysal hamrouni merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors comme en
france comme emmanuel macron boris
johnson a dû se résoudre à le confiner
le pays
quelles sont les réactions au sein de la
population
bonsoir été bon sur la france l'érection
des personnes qui bat ya pas mal de
personnes qui se sentent assez frustré
mais il ya aussi une certaine
compréhension de dire est que vu les
circonstances actuelles par rapport au
virus soit obligé de se retrouver ont
confiné une deuxième fois on dirait je
dirais que c'est qu'il ya un mix des
deux ans
très concrètement comment ça se passe
est ce que quand vous surfez a beaucoup
de contrôle
est-ce que vous avez besoin d'une
attestation de sortie comme en france il
me semble que c'est pas le cas un très
très bonne question
franchement on n'est pas les plus à
plaindre
donc c'est la première journée de
confinement j'ai un enfant dhr j'ai un
regard trop devant on n'a pas de
restriction vis-à-vis des sorties on a
pas de hordes attestation comme lors du
premier confinement on peut sortir au
moins faire de l'exercice il n'y a pas
de limitation pour faire de l'exercice
de encouragés à faire de l'exercice de
mort c'est vrai on nous demande de
rester à la maison
ils sortirent vraiment pour des cas où
il faut travailler étudier donc ya pas
les écoles restent ouverts tard
heureusement c'est vrai qu'on n'est pas
les plus à plaindre
il y avait du monde aujourd'hui dans les
rues de manchester j'ai vu quelques
personnes étaient je dirais que la ville
était un petit peu plus il y avait un
peu plus de monde que lors du premier
grand film ans donc il y avait y avait
du brouillard sur certaines rues pour
être en seat ce soit des rues fantôme
mais il y avait plus de monde que je
dirais lors des premiers confinement
mais les personnels et écoute bien
nous les règles qui ont été mises en
place donc c'est peut-être pour ça aussi
qu'on n'a pas besoin de tes station ici
les citoyens et les british en général
sont plutôt sur plus tôt et écoute
plutôt ce que ce que le gouvernement
leur demande leur demande de faire alors
vous êtes spécialiste dans le digital je
le disais est ce que vous avez
téléchargé cette fameuse appli nhs
qu'ovide 19 qui est deux à la
disposition des citoyens britanniques
ça marche bien non je vous en parle j'en
ai entendu parler
j'ai passé l'été en france et en
rentrant j'ai dû me eumeu séné m'isoler
en faire la 14e j'ai pas télécharger
l'app par manque d'espacé sur mon
téléphone
j'en ai entendu parler parra -
fonctionne plus ou plus ou moins bien
comment les médias traitent ce nouveau
confinement est ce qu'il ya un dilemme
entre la santé l'économie qui est au
coeur des débats
on entend parler à la télévision c'est
clair que je regardais la désinfo juste
un petit peu plus tôt c'est vrai que ça
va un petit peu plombé l'économie un
gars que les magasins dits essentiels
qui sont encore ouverts les supermarchés
les petits commerces les restaurants les
coiffeurs qui en souffrent
malheureusement c'est clair qu'il y ait
beaucoup de gens se sont rués vers les
restaurants les pubs et les coiffeurs
apparemment pas moi mais c'est que ces
pauvres commerçants qui vont subir
parce que vivre ça oui
ici des situations difficiles donc
également pour les petits commerçants
merci fait sanaa moroni pour votre
témoignage depuis manchester où vivez
vous êtes ressortissant
français merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur rt france